I want to mention this quote from the
book it's maybe turning fears about
aging and mortality into contemplation
and comedy is just one of those things
women are better at so what does that
mean to you it's a great statement thank
you
um I guess it was I there's an essay
where I'm talking about uh Nora Ephron
specifically who's a writer I really
admire who wrote um who was an essayist
who wrote a number of essays on aging
and being you know noticing her friends
all wearing like turtlenecks trying to
hide that they were getting older and I
just as a matter of research was looking
into men who've written about aging and
I looked up men
women's necks aging yeah the only thing
that came up was why do are men so
attracted to women's necks and I was
like what like there's no writing
there's no male there is less men
writing about aging in any kind of
comedic way or contemplative way and I
thought gosh this is maybe just
something that women are really trying
to process and and I think it people
talk about it more with women they don't
care they're always like oh he's a fine
wine and you got better as he aged yes
nobody says that about women she looks
so great at 16 you know what I'm saying
nobody's really generally saying that
when they do they're be I find age
beautiful because I have had friends
that didn't make it past 30. like you
know what I'm saying we're lucky I find
these wrinkles I earned these I got
these I agree and it's a beautiful thing
because not everybody's given that
chance to have that lifetime I yeah and
age is awesome age is awesome it's
interesting though that women are maybe
we're more comfortable talking about it
because people projected on us all the
time that I think it's like one of those
things women are good at which is
turning a potential negative into
something that we can learn from or
something to feel that's funny we can
share we can feel positive about we can
laugh with our friends I just think it's
kind of a uniquely female thing at least
in my limited Google research of looking
at points I know I was thinking like I
always think if I die what what are they
going to find in my history yeah and I
love that like boobs of the 90s like
women's necks yeah it's like all the
your your Google history is awesome
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]